so that title is actually not click bait
I did actually in fact almost die a year
ago on April 1st I got a blood clot in
my shoulder I have something called
thoracic outlet syndrome it comes in
three kind of variations where there
isn't enough space between your rib and
the vein the nerve or the artery to kind
of pass through so your arm will then
pinch on either of those three things
and then it constricts the blood flow
causing well a lot of things if it's
nerve it could be pain if it's a vein or
artery it's going to be cutting off
blood flow and in my situation it was
actually the vein and it caused a blood
clot I have a whole video about that but
I feel like so many things this past
year have changed I even feel like my
channel has kind of suffered because I
kind of have gone through this weird
something I don't even know I I can't
even really explain it it's like my
creativity my motivation just
inspiration like everything just kind of
was all over the place but over the past
year I feel like I've been doing more
things I guess for myself I have been
going more places I've been traveling a
bunch again and it's sort of like that
combination of the whole entire world
being shut down for several years and
not being able to go anywhere and now
that things are back opening up again I
don't know I don't even know how to
explain it I'm sort of still I feel like
kind of getting my old self back I've
been finding new hobbies like I started
snowboarding I started going back to jiu
jitsu again and the things that I used
to do like a lot of my sword training
and lightsaber training I don't really
do as much anymore because the doctor
did recommend getting this first rib
removed but there are also a lot of side
effects to that so I decided to not get
the surgery right away but it is
something that I would be willing to do
down the line if something does come up
and I decide to do it again I've just
been kind of being very careful about
the movements like all of the sword
stuff that I used to do like it's just a
ton of repetitive motions all kinds of
things like that like I don't do a lot
of overhead presses and I kind of try to
you know keep down at this this space
level I do still stretch and try to like
strength train a little bit in like my
back so that like my shoulders and stuff
stay open to try to help make more space
over here but really the only way to
make more space is to get the rib cut
out and I did say that if I really
wanted the
um to keep the rib I could so that's
exciting I don't know I just wanted to
kind of give you guys a little bit of a
health update like I'm I feel like I'm
doing well but it's one of those things
that's really hard to test for and my
side effects were mostly like my entire
arm just being super swollen and
thankfully like I kind of knew what it
was and what was happening so I was able
to kind of self-diagnose myself at the
hospital and they were able to quickly
get into action but yeah if you ever do
feel like something is not right in your
body and you know it in your heart in
your soul in your entire being make sure
you advocate for yourself because
sometimes a lot of doctors not that they
don't want to take care of you they are
also super busy like just seeing the
amount of people and patients and things
that they are going through it's not
that they are intentionally ignoring you
because sometimes they don't have the
actual capacity to be able to really
fully give you that attention so you do
have to be persistent and you do have to
keep going and if that person doesn't
listen to you then you're going to have
to find another one and I know that can
be difficult because a lot of insurances
aren't accepted places I am so grateful
though because I did get such incredible
care when I was in the hospital everyone
was amazing in myself like I tried to be
super patient and tried to listen and
learn but I didn't know what was going
on and when you're in sort of this
basically life or death situation it was
such a crazy experience but now kind of
looking back over this last year we made
it through there definitely isn't a day
that doesn't go by that I don't think
about it in some capacity but the crazy
part about blood clots is it can come
from a number of things and I think for
a lot of women it can come from
pregnancies it can come from birth
control which is something that you
potentially might read on the package
and be like that's not going to affect
me well you don't know it could or it's
anatomical like my situation where my
rib is pressing on a vein some people
also have an extra first rib so then
that could also be a factor I'm just
super grateful to be here and I'm just
so grateful that you guys were
supportive through all of that and I
think you guys are all awesome so thank
you so much but I just want to say I'm
doing well it's also been a year since
I've been off caffeine and I think it's
almost five years maybe five six I think
five since I've been off alcohol but
having an experience like that it really
does kind of change your perspective but
also it's strange because it doesn't
even feel like it happened like it's
something that I've kind of pushed out
of the back of my mind and just I know
those first couple of months like
afterwards like I was not well mentally
physically like everything that I used
to be able to do like I wasn't even able
to do anymore so I had to find different
things that I could do to just sort of
fill that void I'm very thankful that
Jiu Jitsu still is something that I can
do and now finding snowboarding has been
really fun and even just like making
videos and stuff is so there therapeutic
because I can like create and I can
actually have something to show and put
out into the world so all of this stuff
is sort of the ways that I've been
coping well thank you guys for watching
and always being so supportive you guys
really did help me get through a really
tough time last year and I'm so glad to
still be here making videos and getting
to see all of you or I guess you seeing
me but me seeing you in the comments you
know what I mean well thank you again
and I will see you guys in the next one
bye
[Music]